the united states has moved into a new
phase in its fight against cobit 19. the
biontech pfizer vaccine is being rolled
out there for younger children
some 28 million kids aged between 5 and
11 are now eligible for the jab take a
big breath
[Music]
in washington dc eight-year-old carter
took his first covid19 jab in his stride
at first i was feeling nervous but
i mean i knew how shots felt so
right then and there i felt fine
carter is one of the first kids to
benefit from the vaccine's recent
approval for young children he's extra
vulnerable because he has diabetes it's
a huge relief for his father brian
the biggest concern for us even as
adults being vaccinated was would you
bring something home
to him and carter
has an underlying condition now that we
have his first shot today
life can start becoming good again
this clinic in texas also had emotional
support dogs on hand to comfort the
youngsters brave enough to turn up on
the first day
it's also a milestone for their parents
getting my children vaccinated is a
priority for me right now not just for
them and their own health and safety but
for the community and that everyone
should be out there doing it and now
they can go tell their friends who maybe
their parents are on the fence that it
doesn't hurt it's no big deal
just come and do it and help protect the
community
the children's vaccine uses a lower dose
than the adult version but also requires
two shots at least three weeks apart
kids who have their first one before
thanksgiving in late november should be
fully covered in time to enjoy the
winter holidays worry free
well for more we're joined now by dr
peter chin hong an infectious disease
specialist at the university of
california san francisco thanks for
being with us dr chinho children are
typically not among the seriously ill
patients filling up covet wards why do
they need to be vaccinated
well terry delta changed all of that in
the u.s in fact u.s hospitalizations of
kids aged 5 to 11
is four times higher than that in the uk
for example i think driven a lot by not
as much testing in schools as well as uh
more chronic conditions like in the
previous story diabetes so i think it's
now one of the top 10 causes of
childhood deaths in the last year so i
think with a 200 percent increase in
cases i think the imperative is uh to
vaccine kids in the united states
polls in the u.s suggest that many
parents there will not be rushing to get
their children vaccinated it's part of a
huge debate what would you say
to hesitant parents
well terry i would say three things the
first is what i just mentioned that kids
can get very sick as well not in some
areas like california but certainly we
saw that in texas and in florida driven
by community transmission large numbers
of people being ill in the community
number two has been very very disruptive
for schools like i mentioned there's not
a
testing strategy that's routine like in
the uk so
one kid gets infected they may not get
sick but everybody else in the classroom
gets sent home there's a lot of chaos in
some school districts thousands of
schools have had these kinds of
disruptions and the third reason that
we've been learning particularly during
delta is that the kids can be a vector
to home i think in terms of what do i
say to the kid or the parent well you
know i think they will have more
confidence in hugging grandma or grandpa
during the holidays they'll be able to
have sleepovers and feel more confident
president biden has called these
vaccines for young children a turning
point against covert 19. how will they
change the trajectory of the pandemic
well terry i think it will help uh
certainly the u.s vaccination
rate in the population after having a
good start has stalled many of the uh
rest of the developed uh world uh
u.s for example about 60 fully
vaccinated as opposed to germany where
it's 66 67
so we need all the help we can and
vaccinating kids will increase the the
the uh rate of the population as a
general being vaccinated
dr chinhun thank you so much for talking
with us that was peter chinhung
infectious disease specialist at the
university of california san francisco
thanks terry
you